merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
vous avez suivi cette cette
manifestation aujourd'hui qui n'est pas
autorisé puisqu'on est toujours en état
d'urgence sanitaire
vous avez été de ceux qui défendent y
est et qui défendent est toujours ce
droit de manifester alors qu'on est en
état d'urgence sanitaire
oui l'état d'urgence sanitaire est une
loi d'exception il ya toujours une
difficulté quand les lois d'exception
d'une certaine façon ce permanent tease
et on vient à devenir des lois générales
vous l'avez constaté avec les propos
absurdes et anti républicain il faut le
dire du ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
castaner il ya 48 heures qui disait que
les manifestations pourraient
potentiellement être organisée sur la
base d'un sentiment si elle était saine
si le sentiment était sain et positif
mais on ne peut pas ainsi faire tomber
la loi est une loi à géométrie variable
en fonction des sentiments donc ce qui
est posé comme question là derrière
c'est bien l'état de la règle
aujourd'hui qui est une règle
d'exception mais qui ne correspond pas à
la période on ne peut pas tenir dans la
durée avec des règles qui ne respectent
pas dans leurs grands principes les
principes constitutionnels et fondateur
de notre pays de notre république
mais on le voit aller les autorités ont
toléré un finalement ces manifestations
la police qui a fait preuve plutôt de
retenue aujourd'hui que pensez vous de
ce bras de fer entre ces manifestants
qui dénoncent le racisme d'un côté et
les violences mais le racisme en
particulier et ses policiers qui eux
manifestent justement parce que ils
trouvent que ces accusations sont
injustes alors il ya deux choses d'abord
je note que comme c'est souvent le cas
avec monsieur castaner ça a été une fois
encore la grande pagaille et c'est une
grande pagaille qui est organisée et qui
vise à créer la confusion et le chaos
si je dis ça c'est parce que le ministre
de l'intérieur et le préfet l'allemand
dans un premier temps avait laissé
entendre que la manifestation pourrait
se dérouler et alors que les
manifestants étaient réunis sur la place
de la république
cette manifestation a été interdite donc
toutes les conditions étaient réunies
pour qu'un moment donné ça se passe mal
et tout cela c'est du ressort des
autorités et notamment du préfet
d'allemands et de son supérieur
hiérarchique
monsieur monsieur caténaire donc cela
sont des fauteurs de troubles
et puis on a tous assisté hier à cette
manifestation d'un syndicat policier
renom j'exagère un petit peu de quelques
policiers parce qu'en réalité on a donné
une grande publicité à quelques
représentants et délégués syndicaux qui
se sont baladés autour de l'arc de
triomphe et sur les sur les
champs-elysées et donc de ce plus de
deux points de vue là on a l'impression
que le pays n'est pas régulé par la
direction par la direction politique qui
laisse les uns les autres
créer un climat de confusion et de
confrontation c'est ce qu'on a vu aussi
aujourd'hui avec la provocation qui a
été menée par génération identité à et
je trouve que ce climat n'est pas sain
et je dénonce la tentative
d'instrumentalisation politique qui est
faite par le pouvoir politique de
monsieur macro et notamment par monsieur
par monsieur casta l'air de jouer sur
cette question là parce que vous avez
bien noté que ce qui était l'objet de la
discussion au début c'était la question
des violences policières et la question
des violences policières et une question
structurelle puisque elle est sur la
table maintenant depuis trois heures
jeudi rennes est en tout cas tout le
monde a vu que les violences policières
sont aussi aujourd'hui un élément qui
permet au régime de tenir depuis le
mouvement des gilets jaunes ces
violences policières aujourd'hui font
débat dans la discussion et on voit que
le gouvernement essaie de renvoyer cette
question là à la question du racisme
il ya une forme d'instrumentalisation de
ces questions de la part du gouvernement
justement pour ne pas avoir à se
confronter à la confrontation sociale
qui elle est en est est en pleine force
est en pleine dynamique dans ce pays en
sortie de confinement et devant la crise
économique qui vient christophe castaner
a annoncé que cette technique de de la
clé d'étranglement seraient abolis quand
et où il ya aussi cette question des
ailes bd qui sont toujours autorisés il
faudrait interdire aussi tous types de
deux techniques en tout cas d'après
d'interpellations et et
et utilisé lors des manifestations qui
pourraient causer des dommages
irréversibles
comprenez moi nous ne sommes pas sur ces
questions-là sur les questions
techniques la question n'est pas de
savoir s'il faut étrangler ou gazés et
si l'un est mieux que l'autre ou pas la
question est que nous avons besoin dans
ce pays d'une police républicaine et
qu'ils aient les moyens d'agir mais qui
soit une police républicaine et pour
qu'il y ait une police républicaine
il faut qu'il y ait une doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre qui soit une
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
républicaine et cela ça appartient aux
politiques de le dire ça appartient
notamment au ministre de l'intérieur
mais il n'a échappé à personne que
pendant le mouvement des gilet jaune
l'air de rien monsieur castaner à
inverser la doctrine de maintien de
l'ordre dans ce pays quand il a commencé
à dire aux policiers et aux forces de
l'ordre que quoi qu'il arrive il était
derrière eux autrement dit que c'était à
eux d'agir et que quoi qu'il arrive il
les soutiendraient dans ce cas là nous
avons changé de régime nous avons
basculé dans une logique autoritaire et
il n'est pas étonnant que nous ayons
connu ce que nous avons connu avec les
gilets jaunes et ce que nous connaissons
encore aujourd'hui il faut donc que le
pouvoir politique restaure l'ordre
républicain est et comment celui même
par intégrer et parent gérer cette
dimension républicaine plutôt que d'être
dans cette absurde de fuite en avant à
laquelle se livre le pouvoir marque
crown east depuis désormais deux ans on
vient de l'apprendre à l'instant
françois cocq le conseil d'état vient de
rétablir la le droit de manifester en
pleine crise sanitaire c'est une bonne
nouvelle
oui c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que
c'est aujourd'hui une liberté
d'expression fortement nécessaire
on voit que les restrictions qui sont
aujourd'hui imposées se font à géométrie
variable et pas dans le cadre du doigt
on voit qu'il y à des mobilisations qui
sont nécessaires je pense notamment à
une mobilisation qui sera sur la base
d'une émotion saine et positive
à mon sens qui sera celle des soignants
qui aura lieu ce mardi et à laquelle
beaucoup de gens au delà de ce milieu là
vont avoir envie de participer
il ya des messages à envoyer et bien sûr
des règles de prudence sanitaire à
maintenir mais il est important que la
vie démocratique puis se reprendre
puisque monsieur macro n'a pas daigné
l'arrêter avec le premier tour des
municipales qui ont fait tant de dégâts
et malheureusement tant de morts
puisqu'on nous dit qu'on peut bien aller
voter le
28 juin il ne faudrait pas que le
mouvement social lui soit bâillonné et
finalement c'est plutôt un bon signal
qui envoyait par le conseil d'état merci
beaucoup monsieur coque d'avoir répondu
à nos questions sur rt france en direct